so as we get into our discussion about
other worlds what we're going to find
here is that we're effectively picking
up with what other realities look like
now the basis behind why this is done is
simply because of the fact that Reed
Richards had created something called a
bridge but Reed Richards didn't
necessarily create this of his own
accord in fact Black Swan had gone to
the Illuminati and said they should
begin the process of creating a mirror
now initially they didn't know what she
was talking about she kept referring to
concepts like needs and wants and so
they didn't know what she meant when she
was referring to a mirror but the more
that she explained it the more that Reed
Richards began to realize that what she
was referring to was a bridge that would
allow them to look into other realities
to see how other realities are handling
the incursions and the entire basis for
this again as Black Swan explains here
is because they need to go into the
incursians event armed they need to go
in being able to see what other
realities are doing and getting a scope
of the bigger picture and so that's
exactly what we'll be seeing in this
video now more so than that what we're
also going to see is not just how these
other realities are handling the
incursions we're going to see different
versions of the Illuminati we're going
to see dr. strange selling his soul at
the sinners market and we're going to
finally see this last world world
designated 4 million 290 and 1 and what
this is going to give us is effectively
the DC Universe within the Marvel Comics
and so what happens here as we start
this story is that again this bridge has
been created and so what happens is we
transition to a new planet called Earth
23 0 99 now remember when it comes to
the Marvel Universe all realities have a
numerical designation earth-616 is the
numerical designation for the mainstream
Marvel Universe everything else all the
other alternate realities have different
numbers and so with this alternate
reality we find the Illuminati are
composed of a relatively different group
although some members are still there we
of course see the Black Panther Black
Panther T'Challa
is still part of the Illuminati but his
sister Cherie is also part of the
Illuminati as well along with
man Charles Xavier Captain Marvel who
apparently did not die in this universe
Black Bolt and Magneto and what we find
out about this reality is something very
interesting what we learn is that
Maximus the mad the brother of Black
Bolt is in fact the king of the Inhumans
in this reality what we also learned is
that the inhumanity event the event on
the earth-616 timeline that had
triggered the Terrigen mists being
spread across the world
had taken place on this reality as well
but the difference here is that the
Terrigen mists had spread across this
reality not because of the actions of
Thanos who had invaded the planet Earth
but for some other reason that is yet
unspecified to us what we also learn
about this entire concept about this
entire world is that because of the
spread of the Terrigen mists that much
like the inhumanity event on the planet
Earth in the earth-616 universe that all
these different Inhumans began to pop up
and so while this entire event is taking
place
the Illuminati come to the realization
that an incursion is coming in that
event an incursion wall is approaching
and so what happens here is we
transition to the city of New York as
this incursion is taking place but what
we see here is the introduction of a new
concept and this new concept is
something called the black priests now
the black priests at this moment that is
to say in this particular comic we don't
know exactly what their motivations are
all we know with these black priests is
they simply arrived on the scene here
now we'll find out later on as we get
into the incursion events specifically
in a perfect world and especially into
time runs out what the motives behind
these black priests are and we'll find
out that one of the Illuminati in fact
goes on the role of leading the black
priests but what happens here is as the
black priests begin attacking New
Yorkers they begin attacking the
Illuminati the Illuminati come across
some very important realizations about
the black priests the first are the
black priests are nigh and vulnerable
not necessarily because the energy
that's being used or the powers is being
used by the Illuminati bounce off the
black priests because the black priests
are capable of some method of Rima T
realization meaning that if they destroy
their physical bodies their bodies will
simply reform again in addition the
black priests use some kind of language
and speaking that we can't fully
understand we have no idea what it is
really saying we see that Charles Xavier
at the behest of Magneto begins to use
his mind powers to effectively scan the
minds of the black priests to read one
of their minds to see if he can figure
out what their motivations are
but what Charles Xavier learns here is
that there is not just one mind that the
black priests are composed of tens of
thousands of minds which make them an
fathomable meaning that they are not
simply something that can be read by a
by a telepathic and so what happens here
is Charl I'm sorry a magneto uses his
powers to remove the helmets of the
black priests and the heads the faces of
the black black priests are revealed to
us
and what we find here is that instead of
eyes they simply have symbols on their
heads now we don't know exactly what the
purpose again of these symbols are in
terms of whether or not there's some
sort of decoration whether or not they
stand for eyes here but again what we
learn is that as a black priests
continue attacking the Illuminati as
they continue attacking the planet Earth
we see that eventually they begin using
their powers using these symbols on
their heads to speak I guess together to
use them to a more or less warp reality
here and what happens is that as reality
is being warped the Illuminati are
effectively disintegrated they are
destroyed entirely but what we also
learn is that apparently the black
priests are capable of detecting when
they're being watched and in fact they
go as far as to say that there are
others watching them here there is a
mirror active indicating they are aware
of the fact that the Illuminati from
earth-616 are watching them as these
events unfold and so what they think is
that perhaps these are the magma map
makers or maybe they're even the ivory
Kings now we don't really know anything
about the ivory Kings even now during
the time runs out a series all we really
know here is that the ivory Kings are in
some way running against Rome along but
we don't really know exactly what their
purpose is or exactly why it is that
they're doing what they're doing and so
what happens here is as the black
priests go about the process of
effectively banding together they
eventually use their abilities to
destroy the planet Earth entirely along
with the entire earth 23 0-99 reality
now the next reality that we jump to is
reality 23:19 and what we find is again
we meet up
this reality's version of the Illuminati
now this version of the Illuminati has a
yellowjacket now whether or not this
yellow jacket is Hank Pym or somebody
else we don't know but the fact that
he's not given a name that is to say
we're not told if it's somebody other
than Hank Pym leads us to believe that
of course it is hanged him what we also
learned is that both Betsy Braddock who
normally plays psylocke in the earth-616
universe and Brian Braddock are playing
the roles of Captain Britain we also see
that again the Illuminati Xhosa Iron Man
and black panther albeit this reality's
version of those characters as well as
Doctor Doom and Emma Frost with read
Richard leading the group and what we
find out about this reality here is that
at some point along the line the Age of
Apocalypse had gone into play but that
this universe had gone through
effectively four different ages of
Apocalypse now whether or not these are
four ages of apocalypse like the one
that we had seen in earth-616 is
something that we haven't seen yet is
something that we don't really know yet
and in fact I don't think we ever really
find out but what we do learn is that as
a result of the ages of apocalypse and
the onslaught that had come as a result
of Apocalypse trying to take over the
world for different times that met that
I'm sorry that mutant kind had
effectively undergone the same sort of
treatment that they did during the Days
of Future past where that is to say they
were basically being hunted down and
rounded up by humans and so what magneto
had done is he created a safe haven a
more or less a a place called heaven
which is where mutants could run to
where they could basically find
themselves safe at and so what would
happen is that again as mutants were
being tracked down that they would track
they would find this new location and
they would eventually travel there and
so what we learn is that as the
Illuminati realize another incursion is
going to be taking place that this
incursion is going to be taking place
within the confines of where the mutants
are at within the location of heaven but
what we also learn here is that while
all these mutants were being tracked
down while all these mutants were being
hunted down that super-powered humans
that is to say these Illuminati weren't
really doing anything to help them they
weren't really doing anything to step in
now the fact that Emma Frost is part of
the Illuminati here we don't know if
she's really a mutant here it could very
well be that she's part of the
a part of a human High Council much like
she was in the Age of Apocalypse or it
could very well be that she's a mutant
and she's simply a representative of the
mutants with regards to to their kingdom
in heaven and so what happens is once
the incursion wall arrives here we
realize that again this heralds the
arrival of the mapmakers and what we're
going to see in the story is what
happens when the mapmakers attack a
planet earth and they're successful and
being able to terraform that earth and
so what we see is that as the map makers
begin to descend towards this planet
earth that they continue I guess they
begin their onslaught on the on the
Illuminati and what happens here is that
for the most part due to the vast amount
of power that is being possessed by the
mapmakers the Illuminati are virtually
powerless against them there really
isn't anything they can do to stop these
Illuminati and in fact the I'm sorry to
stop these mapmakers and in fact these
map makers begin the process of a debt
and adapting themselves to the powers of
the Illuminati and the way the map
makers do this is by effectively
altering themselves to match the RNA or
DNA sequences of various superheroes so
that their powers will effectively have
no effect on them and so while this this
instance is very very short here what we
find is that the the map makers are able
to quickly and easily destroy the
Illuminati
and so the Illuminati are effectively
wiped out on this planet and the the map
makers go about the process of
terraforming this planet now from here
we jump to the story of dr. strange
because while all this was going on
while the Illuminati from earth-616 were
monitoring all of this conflict dr.
strange was nowhere to be found and the
reason for this is because dr. strange
is currently located in a place called
the lost lands and inside the lost lands
is a place called the sinners market now
this is the first time that we've ever
seen the sinners market and in fact I
would go as far as to say the sinners
market has been created specifically for
this storyline by Jonathan Hickman but
what we find out here is that dr.
strange is in this location to seek
something and when the question is asked
of him what it is that he's looking for
dr. strange simply says that he's
looking for power now the initial
response here by his guide is that dr.
strange already has someone
hower already why does he want more and
what he says is that he wants the power
to shake world he wants the power to
remove them from their from the from one
sky and to place them in a new one
effectively telling us that he wants the
ability to move universes to effectively
end the incursions and so what his guide
says is that he's going to be wanting
the resolute throne and so what we do is
we transition to what effectively looks
like a giant box out in the middle of
nowhere and when dr. strange enters this
throne or enters this a room what he
finds is a giant statue surrounded by
several henchmen and what these henchmen
say is that the process I guess of
gaining more power is relatively simple
that they barter in fifths because the
soul of a man is complete and it's whole
and so what they say is that twenty
percent of the power will cost twenty
percent of the of dr. Strange's soul and
so when the question is asked how much
power does dr. strange one dr. strange
simply says all of it indicating that
dr. strange is going to give up 100% of
his soul for absolute power now from
here we transition back to the earth-616
form moment and the reason why is
because what we're doing is we're
picking up with black panther and what
black panther is doing is effectively
going through and continuing to a
chronicle all these different incursions
the ends of these planet Earth's and the
realities along with them and what
happens here is he's joined by name of
the sub-mariner as he's continuing his
investigations and what name of the
sub-mariner does is ask to chollet what
it is that he's learned so far with
regards to the incursions and what atala
says is he's picked up on three things
three important things the first thing
is that the map makers are continuing
their conquest of the multiverse they
are continuing to eliminate various
planets the other thing is that the
black priests are continuing to do the
same thing and so each time the black
priests lay their sights on a planet the
like priests are successful in
destroying that planet along with its
universe and so what happens here is he
says the third thing that he's found and
perhaps one of the more interesting
things here is he's discovered a reality
an alternate earth designated four
million 290 and one where their group
their version of the Illuminati has been
successful in being able to stave off
incursions onto
separate occassions using actions that
are different than what the Illuminati
would normally do and so what we do here
is we transition to those story I guess
to a relatively brief history of this
reality and what we learn is at some
point along the line there was a group
called the archetypes of Justice
now the archetypes of Justice seem to be
as far as we can tell a combination of
namor the sub-mariner the Avengers and
the the x-men combined into one group
now how it was this had happened we
don't know but what we do know is that
this version of Earth was attacked with
an invasion by the Kree and the scroll
with their forces combined now again
whether or not the Kree in the school
were working together we don't know but
what we do know here is that after the
archetypes of Justice that is to say the
combined efforts of all the superheroes
on the planet Earth were defeated that a
new group of superheroes rose up out of
this and this new group of superheroes
were referred to as anti heroes or at
the very least they were part of the
anti heroic age meaning they were
effectively outcasts the reason being
because super heroes were considered
outcasts by the society and with the
actions of these new heroes these six
individuals were able to cast off the
entire forces or the combined forces of
the Kree and the Skrulls and take the
planet Earth back from their own and so
what happens is that a new era of peace
comes about on this planet Earth whereby
superheroes and humans are able to live
together in effective perfect harmony or
at least that's how it appears to us and
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to bring this video to a close and
the reason why is because what this is
going to do is bring us into the final
part of this incursians discussion into
part three where we talk about the
perfect world and we talk about the
final steps that the Illuminati take
with regards to destroying a planet in
order to save their own with that being
said we're going to go and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace be sure to
follow me on Twitter there you can keep
up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly